[Musique]
en pleine pandémie il ya un organisme
communautaire qui viennent en aide à des
personnes souffrant de schizophrénie qui
a décidé de se retrousser les manches
depuis mars dernier l'équipe d'un
couvert à l'autre s'est transformé en
comptoir alimentaire est aussi en
service de livraison tout ça pour
nourrir des personnes confinées ce que
chamboulé pour ces personnes là c'est
vraiment d'être confiné carte un petit
ans et demi chez vous était tout seul
les halls majorque un père qui sont
quelquefois avec les troubles de santé
mentale quand on vit des stress balises
souvent les symptômes augmente même si
le déconfinement s'amorce je voudrais
que la détresse continue à augmenter
l'organisme qui vit de dons et des
subventions a même reçu ce camion de
livraison en cadeau en plus des paniers
entre 200 et 300 repas sont aussi
préparés tous les jours à 3h long de
l'année au carré tout les reste en
octobre qui embauchent et la cafétéria
etc on est vraiment chanceux on dessert
environ 200 personnes sur la rive sud
et il ya aussi ceux et celles qui s'en
sont sortis et qui viennent ici pour
s'alimenter et aussi pour aider les
autres et c'est le cas de ghislaine si
une période un peu dit ça dans ma vie
ici c'est génial c'est vraiment une
famille c'est vraiment des amis la
plupart de mes amis que j'ai connu le 8
1 101 sont bien l'établissement d'un
couvert à l'autre c'est une mine d'or en
soi parce que 1,6 par familiale c'est
possible baptisé tout le monde était
cueilli
il n'y a pas de rigidités comme
tellement au répit donc qui est le
bienvenu et qui permet à ces personnes
de mieux traverser cette crise issigeac
bissonnet radio-canada à longueuil